مياده لماذا نفذت باكستان ضربات عسكريه
داخل ايران ما قامت به باكستان هو رد فعل
على ما قامت به ايران عندما ذفت ما يسمى
بجماعه جيش العدل داخل باكستان حيث ضربت
منطقه بانغور تحديدا وهذا ما اثار حفيظه
الجانب الباكستاني ووصل الامر الى خطوات
منها خطوات دبلوماسيه عندما تم سحب السفير
وكذلك ايضا كان هناك هذا الرد بضربات اعلن
عنها الجانب الباكستاني وقال انها ايضا
تستهدف جماعه تسمى بجماعه تحرير بلوشستان
بالتالي كلتا الدولتين قامتا ب عمليه
عسكريه في اراضي الاخرى وكل منهما تقول ان
ذلك هو خرق لسياده هذه الدوله وكان هناك
اعتراض على هذا الامر وكما ذكرنا ايران
كانت قد بدات الخطوه فكان هذا الرد
الباكستاني الصين دخلت على خط الوساطه
الان بعرضها وساطه بين البلدين لمحاوله
ايه جعل ازمه لا تتفاقم بشكل كبير حيث ان
للدولتين اهميه في المنطقه وكانت قد عبرت
الخارجيه الصينيه عن املها بان تستطيع
الدولتان خفض التصعيد واحتواء الموقف